Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 18th,
2016 what's going on?
How are you?
Um,
I hope you're good.
I hope things are well as everything okay with you and the family.
MMM.
Anyways,
this is the last week of I'm writing forF is for family.
You know,
we've got a table read today and then tomorrow we punch up,
you know,
fix whatever jokes didn't work at the table read.
And then on a Wednesday we were,
we record it and then,
uh,
then I get my wife back.
I'm so fucking excited.
I'm so fucking excited to have this,
um,
behind me all these frigging work and um,
I'm very excited for you guys to see this saint.
Granted it's animation so it'll come out sometime fucking 20,
36 or something.
Um,
I dunno.
Well that's how it works.
That's how the process works.
But I know the big thing is actually writing the scripts and we're finishing it,
uh,
tomorrow after the punch up and then I'm done.
I literally,
I have the same giddiness I used to have.
Remember like the second week of June would just,
even the fucking nerds didn't give a fuck anymore.
Right.
They weren't cleaning their glasses.
They were just showing up.
They didn't give a fuck.
Right.
It teaches would dress and casual.
Everyone just was,
yeah,
it's over.
It's over.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
You know,
it's unbelievable.
I don't get,
you know,
that's,
that's why like sometimes when I look at homeless people,
because everybody just wants to get the fuck out and nobody,
you know,
you just don't want to work.
And every once in a while you look at like these fucking bombs.
And I don't mean like people like try something tragic happened to him.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Like some sinkholes swallowed up the fucking home and then they didn't have
sinkhole insurance and now they're fucking,
you know,
sleeping at a bus station.
I don't mean those people.
I mean the bumps,
the old school Hobos,
the guys out there riding the fucking railroads.
Right.
Let's stick with a handkerchief around it.
When a little peanut butter and fluff and other sandwich inside of it,
those guys got,
they got to figure it out.
They always feel how I feel right now.
You know why?
Because they never have to go to work.
It's always over.
And Hey,
you know,
what do you do?
You go to a new town,
you wash some dishes.
Next thing you know,
you know you're eating beans over a fire outside,
you know,
then with the knife or some shit,
you know.
Does that one how they used to do it or is that just what the actors used to do
when those old movies trying to make an interesting choice?
I want to eat with my knife.
Maybe that'll make me the next John Wayne.
Um,
yeah,
they have it.
Fucking figure it out.
You're never done that.
You never just walked down the street in the middle of the day,
in the middle of the fucking stressful day.
You're coming back from lunch wondering mentally,
how the fuck am I going to get through the next four,
four and a half fucking hours?
He is walked by and you see some homeless guy just fucking just nap and lay it
on a park bench or even on the sidewalk and just so fucking sprawled out and
just see in such a deep level of sleep.
It yet actually looks appealing for half a second.
You know,
I'd love to interview one of those people.
Just be like,
who won the Superbowl this year?
Just to see how out of the loop they are slash how big are sports,
you know,
do you know who tiger woods this?
Do you know what happened to them?
You know,
are you aware that we're at war right now still?
Where were you when it started?
Where you behind a desk?
We are normal.
You know?
Did you have a suit?
Did you sit there and laugh at jokes that you didn't think were funny but just
doing it to try to get to the next level fucking cubicle?
Is that what you did?
At what point did you just decide,
fuck this,
I want to take a nap when I want to nap.
Can you imagine if you were allowed to nap whenever you wanted to nap?
How much better the world would be?
You could just be at work and just be like,
Eh,
you know,
I got to go lay it out for about fucking 20 minutes.
Just go over and curl up in a fucking ball and that'll be it.
You know what I'm trying to say?
People's,
I'm very excited.
As much as I enjoy writing these fucking things,
it's just great dead.
Uh,
you know,
I'm looking at my dog right now.
Just fucking chill it out.
Just fucking lay in that.
She's laying there.
She's,
she,
I don't even know why she's tired.
Fucking tired from all you got damn sleeping.
I'm jealousy.
You cleo,
Cleo,
nothing.
She knows I'm talking about her,
but she doesn't give a shit.
She's fucking tapped out.
She's laying on the rug.
There's a little bit of Sun spilling it from the window,
and she picked the sunny warm part of the rug and that is it.
That's all the fuck she needs.
You know?
No upward mobility.
She's not working on her next fucking season of a,
you know,
fucking the real pit bulls of the greater Los Angeles area.
She doesn't give a fuck.
She's got nothing on our agenda every day.
It's fucking tremendous.
Maybe that's why their lives are only 10 to 15 years,
you know,
they just get to live like all the,
cause when you look at your whole life,
if you're lucky,
you get 10 to 15 years total of just bliss and the rest of it,
you know,
it was just dealing with some cunt,
with coffee breath telling you you didn't have enough,
you didn't bring the right fucking forms.
You got to go back home and go get something else in stand in line again.
That's,
that's what the rest of your life is like.
But if you're lucky,
10 to 15 fucking years of it,
you know,
you get to live like my dog right now,
taking a nap on the sunny part of the rug.
By the way,
there's so much shit going on right now like on the Internet,
on the ear in a web that I just don't understand.
What is the big fucking deal?
You know,
that whole George Bush dancing thing,
I looked that up thinking he was going to be just an absolute fucking lunatic.
Like,
oh,
now stop.
Stop you making all white dudes look bad.
Everybody already knows we can't dance.
It wasn't bad at all.
You look like he was in a good mood.
You know his fucking energy.
It's like I get that fucking energy.
He's,
he's showing up.
He said,
patriotic son of a bitch.
That's his jam.
You know,
he sways a little bit and you know what's great too is in his head he's laughing
at Obama,
like going,
ah Ha,
you still have to do that job.
George pushes on summer vacation and the fucking look he has on his face.
So the same,
look,
I have
all I got to get through.
I just got to get through fucking uh,
basically tomorrow.
Get through the next rewrite and then that's it.
And of course,
you know,
there'll be a zillion punch ups and editing sessions,
but like the fucking daily,
yeah,
grind is a,
it's done.
That's where George Bush is that right now,
if you know he fucking launched the missiles.
All right?
A bunch of fucking people died.
He's mentally past it.
He bought his pieces of land down in South America that sit on aqua firs.
You know?
Who knows?
Maybe he goes out and he gets a fucking 12 peck.
I don't know.
He just looked like a really fucking happy guy.
Since when does a president have to know how to fucking dance?
He does it all.
His fucking job is to get on TV and scare the shit out.
Scare the shit out of you about whatever.
The fucking people above them who want to make money on something.
You know?
We got to get these people.
We got to get those people.
We've got to get some people.
There's some people out there to come and get you coming to get you these
people,
man.
He's playing ball.
They don't lack you.
They don't whack you sitting there on your couch.
It's like,
how the fuck do they not like me?
They don't even know me.
I haven't interacted with these cuts.
You know who has you fuck,
oh,
what did you and your friends do to Piss them off?
You know what I mean?
You went out and you pissed off another fucking country.
Now you're trying to make it seem like they're out to get the I in after me.
They're coming after you.
You can't,
they're never going to get to you.
You know why?
Because you have security and I don't,
and I'm just fucking sitting here sitting here with a mugger fucking t.
That would be great.
Collectively if the world did that,
you know,
in the world leaders,
right?
All of them,
they wanted to start a war.
It'd be like eight people and they'll feel ordinary people,
little fucker.
You know what infidels and all that.
And everybody does.
All regular people just sat down.
I really,
so what's going on?
Well listen dude,
if you got a beef with them,
why don't you go fucking settle it?
Because I've never talked to those people.
And then that's it.
Then we watch it on paper view,
you know,
slap fights,
world leader,
you know,
and it doesn't solve anything other than that.
We just get to enjoy complete fucking sociopathic money,
power hungry,
fucking psychos.
Just slapping each other in the face,
you know?
Then we just get to sit in the crowd eating popcorn gone.
Oh
yeah.
Oh,
just watch him slapping each other.
That's as far,
you know,
something.
If we were really civilized,
that's as far as it would go.
You know,
we just sit there and watch,
you know,
Obama have a slap fight with the al Qaeda guy or a fucking isis guy and then
that would be it.
And there'd be nobody underneath any of them.
Okay.
I wouldn't even be Obama.
It would be the fucking,
the corporate cons.
Who make all the fucking money off the misery.
I'm sorry.
People just that,
that you know,
I don't know.
I hate how they always act like the world is going crazy.
The world is not going crazy.
You just keep showing the crazy shit.
It's like these fucking lunatics said [inaudible] who drove the fucking truck
and to the people.
It's like,
why?
Why did that guy do that?
People never did shit like that,
at least to to the,
to the,
when I was growing up,
people did not do shit like that,
at least as far as the,
the sheer amount of these fucking incidents now.
And I really think it's because,
I think it's the news coverage.
They wanted their last act on earth.
They want people to then be like inside the crazy mind of Joe blow.
He,
he,
he was born in there.
They get to do his whole fucking backstory.
I think that that's what they're going for.
So obviously when something like that happens,
you got to report on it.
But I don't think,
I don't want to know the person's name.
I don't remember how fucking thing up.
But they should die completely fucking anonymous.
And I think if they maybe,
why don't we try that?
Okay.
You know,
instead of,
you know,
the people who get fucking killed,
maybe they talk about him for fucking,
you know,
once or whatever.
But the person who fucking kills everybody,
you know,
they get their own little fucking half hour,
hour long special,
you know,
it new as people sit there with their brow furrowed,
the Sterbai disturbing [inaudible] blah blah blah blah blah.
And they fucking talk about it for 24 hours in and make a zillion dollars in
advertising.
Oh,
I'm a fucking cynical con today.
Absolutely.
But by the way,
that Bush dancing thing was dealt,
was not bad at all.
He looked like he was,
he was in a great mood.
And you know what?
Good for him.
That fucking dope
guys say he's a dope.
I can't really say he's a dope guide.
You guys bilingual,
right?
You got to have some sort of brains in there who's smart enough to realize he
didn't belong at Yale,
so he fucking drowned it in a 12 pack every 20 minutes.
I mean,
I,
I relate to the guy.
Um,
okay.
Anyways.
Oh,
by the way,
if one more person fucking tweets me about that stupid suspension,
the Tom Brady Think d,
the sheer amount of people that don't even understand that,
that has nothing to do.
You know,
like all of a sudden it was proven that Ece,
he is a cheat sheet.
Cheaters.
No,
that's not what that was about.
The first one that was the,
did he cheat and that went to a court of law and was laughed out of court.
The second one,
all that was was the NFL.
They changed their argument.
They go,
we're a corporation.
He's our employee.
Do we have the right to suspend him?
And the court was like,
yes,
you do.
And then they came back and they said,
hey Tom,
remember that fucking trial we had with no fucking evidence whatsoever?
That kind of evidence set gets laughed out of court.
Well,
we're going to uphold it so you're suspended.
So
that's basically what happens.
I just don't,
I don't know people here.
What the fuck they want to hear.
All right.
Um,
all freckles has been working out all freckles.
He's been working out.
I told you I was up to one 86 and fucking change,
uh,
stepped on the scale this week,
one 82 and change towing the first week,
you can always drop three to four,
because it's such a shock to your system of like,
holy fuck,
we're doing this now.
If you just start eating healthy,
working out,
right,
you stop beating around five or six o'clock and just crush waters and you don't
eat again until late the next morning.
You know,
I'm telling you,
if he can drop three to four now,
now I'm in my second week of this shit.
So I want to get down to one 79 and then the week after that one 76.
So I'm in the mid one seventies when I go over to Europe.
So I represent my fucking country properly.
Okay?
All those European concert,
they want nothing more than for me to go over there and be some fat.
Fuck.
You know,
who doesn't know what's going on in the world.
That's what they want.
So what you do is,
is you show up in shape,
right?
You go on Wikipedia,
you Google their fucking city,
right?
You find out what's going on and then you just pretend you're read.
You sit there with your flat stomach and you pretend like you've read.
That's what you do.
And you know what?
It irritates him.
I'm fucking with you anyway.
So I'm down to one 82 and uh,
once 79 next week,
the big seven,
I got to see that man,
that's second number's gotta be a seven.
They can't,
I refuse to be an eight or higher ever.
I just can't fucking do it.
Although having said that at my age,
how slow my metabolism is and how much I like to fucking eat and drink and all
of that shit,
I could easily,
I could hit two bills.
Like if I really,
okay,
like just shut it all down as far as moving around,
you know,
I just stopped doing shows and I just sat here like my dog,
I swear to God,
dude,
I could be 200 pounds by the beginning of October.
Right?
That's not even fucking trying without even fucking trying.
If just ate,
what the fuck I wanted to eat?
I,
oh my God.
Is there a worst site then if fucking
five,
nine and three,
quarter 210 pound redheaded male,
that's not something that you want to see.
And I don't mean muscle,
I just meet coming at you looking like,
you know,
I work at dairy queen and I'm constantly taking advantage of my employee
discount and nobody wants to see that.
Right.
It's not a man looking like my legs,
my pasty fat fucking legs as white as the soft serve vanilla ice cream that I
have every 20 minutes.
So anyways,
I'm going to get down to,
um,
once 79 next week.
Um,
okay.
I just been fucking hitting the God damn elliptical and a dude.
My sciatica is just,
it's completely fucking gone.
Uh,
I'm going for not getting a massage every fucking week.
Right.
That deep tissue.
Just somebody beats the shit out of you and I'm getting all of this stuff.
Okay.
All of these fucking wall is crap that was in my legs from all of these years.
MMM.
Flying on planes,
playing pickup hockey with no hockey stuff.
You know,
they tell you guys that shit.
No,
I don't think I did.
Yeah,
I had a nother fucking massage.
This lady had an elbow jam so far into the back of my leg,
my hamstring.
I was like having memories of every time I fucked up my leg,
she did a spot and I'd be like,
and then I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
that was the time I played pickup hockey.
And all I had was gloves,
a helmet and a stick.
And I was playing defense,
right.
And I'm skating full speed,
you know,
cause we have the puck and all of a sudden they steal it.
And I tried to fucking turn around to go back the other way.
Dude.
And I caught an edge.
Who's getting who I suck at skating.
I could barely go backwards and I fucking shot up in the air and landed on my
left side ass cheek all the way down to my thigh.
I landed so hard,
I didn't even hit my head and I still saw stars.
And,
uh,
that was one of those things where I didn't even try to get up.
I just sat there for a second,
just waiting for everything to settle afterwards and the
bucket,
I got up fast enough before everybody came over and said,
dude,
you are right.
You are right.
You don't want to be that guy.
And I just fucking like,
you know,
skated over to the bench,
one leg working there.
It was just like,
Eh,
hey,
oh hey all the way over.
And I just sat down and like I,
you know,
pick up hockey,
people skate over and they pointed at you.
I shook off like three,
three times before I went back out there and the bruise was so deep,
it didn't show up for like three days.
Like three days later I was on the road and I'm showering and you know,
I thought,
I thought I saw like a bunch of grease on the back of my leg.
I'm like,
what the fuck did I sit on?
And then I saw was a Bruce.
It literally looked like somebody just took a bat and hit me right across the
back of my left leg.
And,
um,
you know,
ever,
this is kind of what I learned.
I thought like when the bruise went away,
then you will all fine.
Uh,
but evidently that's not the deal.
Yeah.
The reason why it takes that long,
I guess for it to come to the surface is because it's so fucking,
whatever you hit was so fucking deep into the muscle.
It took that long for a,
I forget the person explained it to me,
a bunch of busted capillaries or something like that.
And then when they go to heal,
sometimes they confuse to something else.
I don't know,
fuse to a nerve or some shit.
I have no idea.
I don't remember.
I don't pretend to remember,
but all I know is,
um,
a bunch of shit like that happened slash you know,
flying on planes and sitting on my fucking ass and writers' rooms and that's
what's going to happen.
But what I love is,
you know,
all these people who have back problems with telling me that I'll do what you're
going to have this for the rest of your life and blah,
blah,
blah.
I mean,
I didn't fly helicopter for like fucking three months during this because when I
sat down,
my feet went numb and I can't have my fucking feet going numb when I'm trying to
touch the pedals there.
Um,
but no,
I,
if you find,
if you find a fucking,
a real Mizuho's of fucking incredible one,
they can figure out what the fuck's wrong with you.
And even beyond a chiropractor,
they beat the fuck out of you and they loosen everything up and then everything
relaxes and you go back to be normal.
At least that's what the fuck happened with me.
And uh,
I flew for the first time Wednesday.
Uh,
it was tremendous.
It was tremendous
of Jesus Christ of at that is that,
that's a,
is that a fucking raven?
Hey,
hey,
hey yo man,
get out of here.
Jesus Christ.
How old am I that I had to yell that long in a bird before it left back in the
day I stepped on a stick in the fucking thing took off.
What does that mean?
Was that a cro or a fucking raven?
All right.
We got to look this shit up here.
Some fucking ancient medieval history shit for you,
Raven.
Uh,
what do you say here?
Raven.
I'm Super Raven.
Superstition.
Alright,
let,
what do we got here?
What do we got here?
Ravens.
Symbolism.
Okay.
Myths of the Raven,
symbolisms and lore.
Learn about the lore of Ravens bar.
I know.
That's what I'm here for.
All right.
The Raven often has a bad press for being a Carrion Carrie and burn.
I know what that means.
It is ultimately associated with death.
Tremendous.
Finally getting fucking healthy.
Now I'm going to die and consequently considered a bad omen by many or a
forewarning of war.
Not Jesus knee is going to yell at me,
but there is much more to this egg,
egg,
nomadic and intelligent bird than death,
darkness and destruction.
Raven is a trickster or protector,
a teacher,
and a bringer of great magic.
I would love to see the person who wrote this,
like what they would dress like.
I just picture them and like a fucking Toga with the leaves.
You know the hats.
They'd have leaves on the side.
It's like if he had a full head of leaf hair and then you went bald,
just fucking wrapped around.
You learn all about the raven and it's Laura here.
Well,
that's what the fuck.
I'm here for your comments.
All right,
so raven is not only the largest member of the crow family.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Okay.
It's the big brother,
but the largest perching bird in the world.
Okay.
I thought they all perched.
The Ozu lay down and extremely intelligent bird.
The Raven was once extremely common,
but persecution now finds it only in remote areas such as cliffs,
mountains,
and moon and more moods and morse.
It's amazing the amount of English words.
I don't know what they are at Morris.
I thought those were Africans.
I just,
I don't fucking,
I don't.
I evidently it was a crow because I don't have any of those things.
Okay.
No cliff.
There's no mountain.
I have a porch.
The adult is completely black with a shaggy through.
I don't care.
What the fuck does it mean?
Ravens are extremely intelligent in some cases can even learn to talk.
All right.
That wasn't a fucking raven.
I was just yelling at it.
Hey,
hey.
Would've been like,
what?
Yeah.
That would have freaked me out.
I'd be like,
Oh,
you know,
it was just one on one or if you'd leave,
there'll be cool.
The wolf and the Raven are often mentioned together and mythology.
Laura and scripture in nature,
the wolf and the Raven Heaven important relationship.
Wolves use ravens as an Ariel Ariel spotters for possible sources of food as
well as using them to alert them of danger ahead.
The Raven also gains from this relationship with the wolf being carrying birds.
I'm so sick of reading that fucking word.
What does it mean?
You know it's funny.
The amount of people that are listening to this right now.
And they feel superior to me cause they know what this word means.
Yeah.
And what does that Kenny,
is that going to buy you a sandwich today?
The decaying flesh of dead animals.
Okay,
so that's what it needs.
All right,
so it's like a fucking,
it's like one of those birds.
A vulture spreads with the fucking redhead.
No fucking feathers.
I know why they don't have feathers on their heads because they're always eating
a dead carcasses and they don't want the maggots to get in there.
So they do whatever fucking bacteria and shit gets on their head.
Just gets burned off by the sun.
Although I can't tell you I look like a raven after not a raven.
If I look like a fucking vulture,
if I go to the beach,
big fucking redhead,
you know,
and I eat dead meat too.
Right?
Ham Sandwich.
That's a dead pig.
Jesus Christ.
This is an incredible article.
All right.
The Raven also gains from its relationship to put the,
okay,
obviously if the wolf fuck and kill something,
what?
Jesus Christ.
I don't think I can find two more boring animals on the planet than those two
fuckers.
I think they deserve each other probably both in bed by eight every night.
Um,
all right,
let me,
let me do a couple of fucking reads here.
You got a lot of advertising.
We didn't have any on fucking Thursday so I got to make up for 'em.
Okay,
I got to make up for this shit here.
Alright.
Hey,
uh,
hey.
Um,
no,
no.
That's a read.
Actually here I need the advertising.
Where the fuck is he advertising?
All right.
Hey Billy,
his grip strength,
uh,
you fucking jerk off.
He did the same one twice.
So it really going to be one of these days.
All right,
hang on a second.
People,
I apologize.
Hang on.
Content reads.
There we go.
Are Ah,
here we go.
Track her.
Everybody.
Smart cars,
smart phones,
smart homes.
Technology has made everything wicked smart,
but losing your stuff,
make smart people feel really stupid.
Kid Tracker makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bag,
computers,
anything in seconds.
Just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and it finds the precise location with the tap of a
button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone,
press the button on tracker and your phone rings even when it's on silent.
All right,
this kind of creepy,
uh,
with over 1.5 million devices,
tracker has the largest crowd gps network in the world.
So your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with track or why don't I get this fucking thing?
I lose my phone all the time.
Listen to the,
did this show to get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the track or t h e t r a C K e r.com and enter the Promo Code [inaudible]
B u r are the hardest single single I have to find you'll ever have to find.
Is there a website?
Go to tracker.com right now and use the Promo Code [inaudible] for 30% off your
entire order.
Again,
tracker.com Promo Code Bar.
Oh look who's back club.
Debbie club.
Debbie,
I own land on an aquifer club.
back to drinking booze delivers wind straight to your door.
They send you wine that is personalized to your palate slash.
Taste through your own.
Through our pallet quiz.
Their recommendations become even more personalized with every bottle you rate.
Club.
Debbie,
I like to sway when I dance.
Works with top wine makers and growers from around the world,
uh,
directly to make all of their own wine.
You choose the type quality of bottles with no membership fee or cancellation
fee and 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Uh,
there are $13 bottles would normally retail for 20 bucks.
Right now club Debbie alcohol couldn't beat me.
Is offering listeners $20 off your first order when you go to club Debbie
at.com/burr and it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So clamp Debbie,
they don't let me go to Bilderberg anymore.
We'll actually pay for your shipping on orders of four bottles of more.
So take something off of your to do list.
Just go to club Debbie a.com/berg to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club Debbie at.com/burr.
All right,
score big everyone.
You know what?
You're paying too much for tickets between all the markups and last minute
convenience charges.
Even printed home,
even printed home feast the ultimate fuck over.
You end up paying courtside prices for nosebleed seats.
Scorebig is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live ticket events go on sold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats?
That huge savings.
It's called score.
Big
Score.
Big works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats.
It unpublished prices only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off Jesus Christ.
They're making some big claims here.
One,
go to score big.com or download the new score,
big APP for your iPhone and find the event and seats.
You want to make an offer.
Why?
Why don't you do this with the Superbowl?
Because evidently 40% of those tickets go on sold and you can pay for less,
less than a ticket value.
These guys were amazing.
To make an offer with score,
big name and a ticket price feature three,
get an instant answer and say up to 60% off your ticket for what game?
Fuckheads state versus a Soliloquy,
something or other.
Uh,
for easiest for the easiest ways to save tickets,
download the new score.
Big App for your iPhone.
Enter Promo code birth at the checkout and you'll save an extra 20 bucks off
your first ticket purchase.
No iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online when you go to sport score big.com.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bar,
right score big.com Promo Code [inaudible] I'm going to try those guys.
Oh Jesus fucking Christ.
We got like 20 of these.
Oh look who's back bait back.
Mejan ds me undies live and on an aqua for boo Doo doot Doo me undies,
me,
Andy's,
get some for him and her wrap up her twat or your balls.
Then walk into the fucking water falls,
you balls stay dry.
Even if they're cold,
they fucking travel up all yeah,
and pull into your body so you don't freeze to death.
All right?
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spent almost 24 hours a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
your underwear is probably boring me.
Andy's is here to change that.
Um,
every pair of meundies is made from sustainable source modal modality of fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing could describe the fit and the feel of me undies.
But once you try them on and you'll understand why they're,
why they are called the world's most comfortable underwear.
And if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they are free.
No questions asked me.
UNDIES has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear.
Where there anyone can see them or not.
Remember,
superman shipping is free and the United States and Canada,
he can save up to $8 a pair with the Andy subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair,
get 20% off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash Pir for 20% off your first daughter.
Hey.
Yeah,
and he's dot com slash birth all right,
there's three left and I'm going to read those later.
Let's get back to the fucking podcast.
Here I am sweating here.
Roche didn't bake in Boyd.
Um,
you don't actually checked in.
I checked in on the world of baseball.
I have not looked at all my fucking Boston Red Sox,
if I can call them that or a game out behind the Baltimore Orioles and we're in
between two dirty birds,
Orioles and Blue Jays,
right?
Yankees are in fourth.
Tampa Bay's bringing up the fucking rear.
Here's what's interesting to me in first place.
You got Cleveland.
All right.
You got Baltimore.
They have not won a world series since 1983 you got the Cleveland Indians.
They haven't won since like fucking was in 1948 or something.
Texas has never won.
You got the Washington senators,
they're in first place.
They used to be the expos.
They never want.
They should have won in 94 but the fucking strikes fucking cutoff the whole
season.
The Chicago cubs,
they haven't won since 1907 and then the San Francisco giants who've won every
other year,
this decade.
All right,
look at that to fucking Los Angeles Dodgers and only game and half out.
I have no fucking clue because they're not on my cable service because they had
some fucking country country fight with somebody.
It's just the worst.
So this is pretty cool,
man.
What a great year for baseball.
You know?
All right.
If I had,
if I could see Baltimore,
Cleveland or Texas,
I would pick Cleveland.
If I could see Washington cubs or San Francisco,
you got to go with the cubs,
right?
No,
they're foofy fucking fans taking their shirts off at the fucking games.
They don't give a shit.
Right?
So if it was Cleveland first to cubs,
you know,
I got to go with Cleveland.
They just won an NBA title.
Let's see them get the fucking,
you know,
the monkey off their back with baseball.
And I would root for the cubs,
but I just don't think that people care enough every time it's ca may out towed
up,
all gay.
It's just too fucking happy there.
And I also blame them.
I really feel like because they do that stupid shit in the seventh inning.
That's why the fuck in,
uh,
you know,
the Yankees Play,
why MCA?
And that's why the red sox play that fucking horrific sweet Caroline.
The cubs started it.
Okay.
And because you created that,
and I have to go anytime I see a red sox game and I have to watch a woman put
her head on the shoulder of a boyfriend during the seven things stretch is
everybody sing said horrifically creepy fucking song.
You know,
I kind of hope the cubs go another hundred and fucking six years.
100,
they're up to 108 years.
You know what I mean?
Not even the Phillies went that long.
The biggest losers and professionals and then always want lots more fucking
games and those cons.
Um,
and they went,
almost done.
They went from like 1880 to 1980 are like 1882 to 1980 let me see.
Chicago cubs,
last world.
Look at that.
Comes right up.
1907 I'm sorry.
okay.
What'd you look at that?
So it's been a hundred and fucking eight years.
They should keep it going at that point.
You know what I mean?
You just,
you just be who you are.
Right.
Plus the fucking white sox one.
One.
I don't understand cities that have to fucking teams.
I just don't get it.
And one of the team wins it and you don't go to the parade.
It's like it's it.
It represents you city.
How many fucking teams do you need?
New York City,
evidently,
in order to remain successful for as much shit as New York City talks,
they need two football teams,
two baseball teams,
two basketball teams and two hockey teams.
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
I Dunno if you come from a real city like Boston,
you just need four and a fucking soccer team and they'll all went championships.
If you know what the fuck you doing,
you don't have to hedge your bets doubled down in every fucking sport telling
you,
okay.
You know,
it's really making,
my day is Rapaport is just been lately.
The Guy,
he's just,
he just won't fucking leave me alone.
He was all,
he was another one guy all excited about the Tom Brady fucking,
I was like,
Michael,
I agree with the suspension.
A corporation should be allowed to suspend an employee,
even if it is complete horseshit.
He,
I just don't,
he's a giants fan.
They fucking own the patriots in the Superbowl.
Why can't he just be happy with that?
You know what it is about New York fans is when they look at Boston fans,
they don't see the misery anymore.
You know,
we can talk shit.
It's fucking great and they don't know how to handle it.
They want us to be miserable again and we're not,
and it's driving them nuts and like the misery that Rapoport has that I'm not
miserable.
That's the kind of people that these New York sports fans are.
That's why they got to get all of these fucking teams.
They're like a fucking,
uh,
they're like Walmart.
They're trying to fucking,
you know,
I have so many locations.
They put everybody else out of fucking business.
It's just,
it's not going to happen.
It's not going to fucking happen.
All right,
so why don't,
why don't you get three teams in every sport then?
Maybe you could run the table in 10 years.
You fucking cunts.
All right.
Um,
oh God.
Who would ever thought is a Boston sports fan?
I could just sit here and laugh at New York sports friends.
I never thought that that was going to happen,
you know?
And here I am all fucking happy.
Uh,
fuck.
What am I up to?
36 minutes.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
All right.
Hey,
let's do some reads here.
Billy,
grip strength.
I'm one of your listeners wrote in last week,
uh,
wrote in last week to ask about his hairy girlfriend.
I'm not sure what he ended up telling her or if he sent you an update.
But unfortunately,
I've had experience with this on a couple of occasions now,
for those of you who didn't listen to the other day,
this guy was dating this Brazilian woman,
you know,
so you know she's fucking smoking hot,
but you know,
she just had a little issue.
She had a little bit of further are fucking arms and uh,
with a tramp stamp would go,
you know,
the tattoo could get lost in the weeds,
if you know what I mean.
So he wanted to tell it a fucking wax a little bit.
Cause you know,
I mean Jesus Christ,
you don't doing it doggy style.
She's got like a fucking Afro,
just have up a booty crack.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean what,
what,
what's going on with that?
So,
but how do you tell somebody that,
I mean,
women can tell guys that in a second,
like,
you should wax your back.
I Dunno.
You know,
it just grosses me out.
And you're like,
all right,
if that's what it takes them,
you keep fucking me.
Right.
You can't tell these ladies anything.
You know,
honey,
I love you to death,
but you're back.
Reminds me of Gabe Kaplan.
Um,
I had an experience with this on a couple of occasions.
under no circumstance should you ever tell her she's Harry.
I was dating an Indian broad for awhile and she had excessive hair growth on her
forearms,
lower back,
feet and toes.
But worst of all,
nose hair.
Let that he said,
imagined.
Let that image sinking is what you wanted to say.
Uh,
this check was super cool and very attractive,
but the hair situation was bothering me so I broke up with her at her place,
but made the mistake of telling her why.
Oh God,
dude,
why would you do that?
Let it be known.
This was a bad idea.
Well,
no,
dude,
if he's just told her,
you know,
there was a way you don't,
obviously if you fucking and listen,
I'm breaking up with you.
I think you're a sweetheart,
but physically I can't deal with all of your hair.
Yeah,
that's going to devastate her anyways.
Okay.
Long story short,
she flipped her shit and threw plates,
silverware,
pots,
et Cetera at me was screaming and crying.
So I left when I came back later for my shit.
She had thrown bleach on some of my clothes and stapled condoms to the wall.
You could say things got hairy,
lol.
Why do women just get to just destroy men's property all of the fucking time?
You don't like if the cops show up and she's throwing all your shit up,
they do a light sweet.
I'll comp calm down.
I started just getting the car.
Just just get away from her sister.
She calms down.
It's destruction of property.
There's like a zillion youtube videos of,
of
women just destroying their guys cars.
I don't understand it.
I really think men should start prosecuting them.
Them them for this shit.
We always just go like,
hey dude,
she fucking flipped out.
Whatever.
I can get another flat screen.
Just get her away from me.
I'm all in all he said,
um,
if the listener hasn't told this lady about his displeasure of her hair,
I highly recommend he doesn't.
Well,
dude,
you fucking told her.
He should have just said listen in,
but that's the fucking reason you were going to break up with that.
You should not have brought it up.
What did you say?
Yeah,
listen to.
we,
uh,
we got to talk.
MMM.
This isn't working for me.
Why?
Yeah.
I'm just not happy.
Well,
what is it?
Did I do something?
I said something.
I said,
what's the problem?
Uh,
you're,
you're too Harry.
You have hairy toes.
You have hair above your ass and it's coming out of your nose.
And I just,
you know,
you just reminded me of John Matousek and I just,
it's turning me like why would you do that to somebody that what you did serve
was fucking mean.
Um,
on once one,
pardon me,
actually.
Okay.
Respects the fact that you actually communicate and even was fucking mean is
you're going to get what you want in life.
If you,
if you just don't give a fuck about other people's feelings to that level,
you're never going to end up trapped in a fucking relationship.
So it's good that you do that,
but in the future,
surf,
you're going to broke at,
break up with something,
some something,
somebody because of something physical,
you know,
it keep that to yourself.
You know,
cause who's kidding who?
Dude,
that's not the only reason why you broke up there.
You know,
if you get good at fucking teller,
she was too fucking hairy.
If you're still liked her,
why won't you just say,
listen,
can you do me a fucking favor?
You got hairy toes.
Can we start off with that?
Jesus Christ.
I was like,
I'm dating a fucking cave woman.
It's 2016.
Have you watched any porn or when your life,
all right,
on a side note,
he said,
you mentioned your home gym and current workouts,
but I've never heard you talk about dead lifts.
Do you plan on doing them?
And if you already do,
what type of progress are you making?
Thanks to go flog yourself.
What is a dead lift?
Is that the one where you fucking bend over at the waist and pull it up?
Or is that the one where you fucking,
you act like you're in the Olympics and you lift it up over your head.
Um,
both of those look like something I shouldn't be doing at my age.
All right.
Videos,
deadlift.
All right,
five common mistakes.
The dead lift.
All right,
here we go.
Oh Jesus.
What is this for that?
So that's the one,
the old blow out your back one.
No.
If you use proper form,
does the lifter have an Instagram?
His hip should be the first things that move.
There's a lot of vital information missing from this hips,
hip wide stance hands just outside.
They have full grip of the bar.
Shoulders slightly in front of the bar.
Lumbar curve maintained.
So add Shabak yeah,
dude,
I'm going to give a big fuck that to that exercise unless you can tell me what
the hell it does to me other than increase my chances of blowing out my back.
Um,
okay.
I,
I just kind of what for legs?
I go hiking and I do,
I do body weight exercises,
you know,
the same way I do grip strength stuff.
I'm really into just being able to move my fucking body.
I don't need to pick up a car.
Like I'm grabbing it by bumper and try to use my fucking proper form.
But um,
who knows,
you know what,
I'll,
I'll look those up,
you know?
Okay.
I'm sure I'm going to get a big fucking lecture on.
Oh my God.
You don't do dead lifts.
You might as well Nubby we're good at it.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
dear,
uh,
bald as Billy Gunn,
regarding your caller.
Who needs advice on getting his girlfriend to shave off body here.
Okay,
here we go.
I would like to tell,
tell him to be careful what he wishes for.
I had a girlfriend with really hairy arms and because of it she had very low
self esteem.
Once we got to college,
her friends took her to a beauty salon and she had her arm hair waxed.
Shortly after she read,
she started to receive a lot of new male attention and pretty soon had little
time from me.
Shortly after she told me she needed to talk though.
Jesus.
Yeah,
she moved up in the draft.
She had a good combine.
Um,
she told me she didn't want to limit her options in college.
Good for her.
He goes,
I was devastated.
I told her that since I found her attracted,
when nobody else did that,
that should count for something.
Um,
she replied with,
we all make mistakes and walked out cheeses.
Anyways,
consider your moves carefully before doing something brash.
Thanks for the sub par podcast and go fuck yourself.
Ps,
take it easy on guys writing to you for solutions.
They are obviously at rock bottom.
If they are willing to take advice from a dyslexic freckled con Jesus.
This guy took two shots at me.
Um,
um,
uh,
you know,
that's fucking brutal.
And that's,
once again,
that is something where,
where it,
when it was going the other way,
women would be like,
that's brutal.
But then if they read this same fucking story and as much as they dumped you,
she dumped you when you accepted her for who you were,
they would all be like,
that's right.
Go girl.
You go get what the fuck you want life.
Um,
dude,
that's kind of fucking funny.
I mean,
does that fuck with your self esteem at all?
I think it did.
I think that's why you gave me shit.
Not once,
but twice.
At the end of it.
I think he got a little bit of anger,
which I would have had anger too.
Jesus Christ.
You know what's funny about that is like she,
if she keeps fucking doing it in enough time,
goes by the next guy who dates or is going to have no idea that that's part of
her fucking genetics.
And then he's going to have a little hairy baby can be like,
where the fuck did this come from?
She's be like,
ah,
you know,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Fucking baby coming out looking like Robin Williams arms.
Remember his fucking furry arms rest his soul.
Um,
oh my God,
that's fucking
everything.
Anything that happens to a guy just,
it just ends up being funny.
I Dunno what it is.
Everything that happens to a woman is tragic,
but just when shit happens to guys,
it's fucking funny.
What are you going to do?
You know what you're going to do buddy?
You go to the fucking gym,
right?
You go to the gym and just go,
you know,
just start hitting,
not at tit,
non shit way out of your fucking league.
You know,
do it.
Do it for yourself,
man.
She's reaching for the fucking stars.
So should you take that as an inspiration and,
uh,
you know,
God helped the next fucking guy.
She gets with Jesus fucking Christ.
And then,
you know,
some the whole time she walks this earth,
she has to live with that secret.
You know,
cause I'll tell you,
there's no fucking way she's telling the next guy that that's what's going on.
If that held her back.
Right.
And you know,
when she walks around and hangs out with all these other fucking beautiful women
now in her beautiful people circle and they have like fucking no hair on their
arms,
there's going to be something in the back of her head,
you know,
and one day she'll have too many whites,
infant Dales,
and she'll just say to her,
fucking boyfriend,
no,
did you go?
Maybe she won't.
And then someday they have the hairy baby,
the old h base,
the dreaded hairy baby.
I can't come into work today.
Oh,
it's a matter.
Uh,
my wife gave birth to a heavy baby.
Yeah,
dude,
it's fucking ridiculous.
I thought it was,
I thought it was a little gorilla.
Oh,
turns out she had fucking hair all over.
She just got waxed.
All right,
dear red,
red Sonja.
I don't know what that means.
I hope I said Sonjay.
S O n.
J a.
Um,
should I look that one up?
I mean,
if it's an insult,
I got to see what it is I want to share on the left.
Other than the fact I can't pronounce it or know what it is.
Red Sonja,
what is red?
Sonja Red Sonja in 1985 is a vengeful woman sets out to achieve a magic orb with
an er.
I got to see images of this.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
She's fucking smoking hot.
Um,
I don't know what that means,
but anyways,
dear red Sonja,
um,
heard the email from the guy with the hairy Brazilian girls is another one.
Yeah,
this is another one.
There's a lot of hairy ladies.
Um,
I have a suggestion for the other guys in similar situations.
Uh,
have bill burr address it for you.
Listen to the podcast over the speakers when your girl is home.
That way,
you'll plant a seed in her brain and hopefully get her to shave with an wax
without even addressing it yourself.
Oh,
so play that fucking part of the podcast when they're around.
Uh,
you know what?
Women are way more complex than that.
That's a fucking decent idea and uh,
cause what's going to happen and show if she self conscious about that,
if the light goes off,
she's going to be like,
that's first.
She'll be like,
that's stupid,
Eh,
that guy shouldn't have blah,
blah,
blah.
And then about a half hour of that bull shit,
she'll finally come around to saying like,
do you think there's like,
I know I'm a little more hairier than most girls.
Does it bother you?
It's still going to come back to you.
If women wear that fucking easy to deal with emotionally,
we wouldn't die eight years before them.
There's no fucking way it would be that easy.
Like they're just going to listen to the podcast and they just going to click.
It'd be like,
Oh wow,
maybe I should wax.
I'm going to do that and not have a fucking four hour un meeting with my fucking
boyfriend.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I've done the same thing in the past with great success.
Okay,
maybe I'm wrong.
Wait a minute.
Wait A,
here's the replay going over to the replay booth.
Uh,
I happen to listen to an episode.
He said,
I happened in quotes to listen to an episode about lip hair when we were
driving.
Three days later,
mustache was gone.
Try it.
It just might work.
Holy Shit.
All right,
well fuck it.
Give it a shot.
I stand corrected.
I Apologize Sir.
I Paulista apologize.
Jesus Christ.
I just pictured the,
the referee coming back saying no goal,
but he actually came back,
said the goal was allowed.
You lost sight of the puck and the mustache still left.
It's incredible.
All right.
All the best from Sweden.
Okay.
What am I up to here?
50 fucking minutes.
All right.
Okay.
Career crossroads.
Hey Billy.
Fuck face.
I like tech guy.
He just,
he didn't try to be creative.
He just went right for it.
I am a 17 year old high school senior.
Going to into college,
studying prelaw and ever since I was young,
I wanted to go into the military.
My father owns a medical compliance company and his promised me a job after
college.
Should I get a law degree?
However he was,
Archie says Christ.
You know what?
I just realized I got to do something.
Hang on.
I got to start this fucker.
I'm going to hit pause and I got to start this fucking question over again.
I got to unlock the door here.
Hang on.
All right,
I'm back.
I didn't need to unlock the door.
She had a Keith for some reason I think she had a keys.
Um,
and she's the lovely knee is going to come on hopefully in a minute and dress
the fucking,
the growing controversy of they Harry girlfriend.
How do you tell her?
All right,
so here we go.
Hey Billy.
Fuckface.
Uh,
I am a 17 year old high school senior,
going into college studying prelaw.
And ever since I was young,
I wanted to go into the military.
Um,
my father owns a medical compliance company,
has promised me a job after college.
Should I get a law degree?
Why would you get a law degree and then working in a medical compliance company?
Oh,
medical.
I thought I was thinking like they supplied like appliances,
like he was selling like fucking dental drills and shit.
However,
he has recently talked about selling the company and retiring as he is nearing
70.
Uh,
and not getting any younger.
My question is this,
after I finished college,
should I enlist in the military something that I've wanted as long as I can
remember or should I stick with the safer option?
Never choose safe taking over my father's business slash securing a safe
lifelong career.
Now do that.
That is a recipe for what if,
um,
fuck that dude.
You're young.
You don't have any kids.
Just risk,
risk,
risk.
I'm not saying fucking jump off a bridge here.
I'm just saying,
yeah,
go big.
You go big when you're young.
You know she'd never go out with me.
Fucking ask her out.
Who gives a fuck?
Right?
Oh my God,
I can't.
I can't try to do that.
That's a one in a zillion chance.
Just go fucking do it.
Listen to how I read out loud,
how fucking horrific I am,
and I've been tremendously successful telling shit jokes now if I can do it,
believe me,
anybody can do it.
And you can too.
If that's what you want to do,
you should definitely do it.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I'm worried that during my absence in the military,
there's a strong possibility my father will say,
screw it and sell the business.
I'm at a loss because on one hand,
I don't want to sit at a desk 10 years from now thinking about what could have
been a great experience in the military.
But on the other hand,
I don't want to lose a job at my fault at my fathers and be stuck at a soul
sucking law firm for 30 years in a tiny cubicle working to make someone else's
dream come true.
I'm really at a crossroads here and I don't want to make the wrong choice that
could potentially fuck me over big time.
Uh,
what would you do if you are my shoes?
Thank you.
And Go fuck yourself.
I would go into the military,
I'd finish your law degree.
That's what you want to do.
I would go into the military,
joined the branch that you wanted to.
I would fucking crush it in the military and then when I come out I would be
such a,
you know,
I would attack being a lawyer at the same,
yeah,
the same attitude.
Why do you feel like you're going to be stuck in a tiny,
tiny cubicle?
Why wouldn't you move up and become partner?
You need to dream bigger dreams.
Dude.
This whole thing of like,
you know,
the only way you're going to be successful in the business world is if you take
it job for your dad.
Fuck that dude.
If you go the other route,
you become a self made man.
And when you become a self made man,
you get a belief and a confidence in yourself and um,
okay.
You don't worry.
Like you're 17 you're already,
you're already worrying.
Fuck that.
You got your whole life ahead of you.
I would go out and do everything that you want to do.
And then one day,
all 20 years goes by and all of a sudden you're like,
Holy Shit,
I work for myself.
I'm making great money.
I can go to the movies whenever I want to.
I can take a vacation,
you know?
Yeah.
I could talk shit on a podcast like it.
It just completely opens the world,
opens up for you.
But you know,
if he'd go the safe route,
you know,
there's that,
there's that does that fucking nine,
that haunting voice in the back he had,
what if I did this?
What if I did that?
You start sleeping at night.
All right.
Fucking thrashing and Shit.
Um,
I think you're going to do great in the military and I think you'd do great as a
lawyer and that's what you should be thinking.
You know,
that's it.
And you're going to meet some fucking beautiful woman in shoe.
You'd get married or whatever.
Whatever the fuck is you want to do.
Just think positive thoughts and a,
surround yourself with people that feel that way.
And if you have a friend that sees you start to do well and you feel them
starting to become negative,
address it.
And if they don't fucking clean up this shit,
you cut them out of your life because those people will bring you down.
Stay here at the townie bar with the old football jacket on.
Fuck that.
All right.
Good luck to you,
sir.
All right.
Dating an older lady and all the broad.
Hey Billy boy.
Fuck not uh,
Ben in a serious relationship with an older woman.
She is fantastic.
Cooks for me,
rubs my feet,
gives me sponge baths.
Jen,
just an absolute gem.
She has a great job,
makes a boat load of,
uh,
cash,
I guess.
S Carol,
I don't want to say that word.
And I also do very well for myself.
Money is not an issue.
I deeply care for her and love her.
I'm 30 and she is 45,
but she looks better than most girls my age.
When we first met,
I thought she was 32.
So that's what initially attracted me to her.
She's fucking slamming hot and a great purse and has a great personality.
We can joke around and I can say disturbing things to her and she just laughs.
Real class act type of broad.
Uh,
she was an 18 year old daughter.
She has an 18 year old daughter,
but as far as I'm concerned,
I don't really give a flying fuck.
My family had some opinions and we're like,
she's too old,
blah blah blah.
Fuck them.
They have miserable relationships.
She makes me a better person and I feel good.
Your thoughts,
uh,
your thoughts,
Billy Little sack Jesus Christ.
Fucking everybody.
They gave me the old fucking one,
two there.
Um,
well dude,
you sound like you happy.
That's what the fuck you want.
The what?
There's nothing wrong with it.
Yeah,
that's what you want.
There's nothing fucking wrong with it.
She makes you happy.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Why would you leave?
You know,
I don't know if you want to have kids that,
that would be a fucking issue.
You know,
at that point you've freezer fucking eggs and you jerk off into something.
I don't know how it works.
I don't pretend to be a doctor.
Um,
I'll fuck you know what?
I didn't read the other God damn
you.
Other advertisements.
All right,
let me just knock out these last
really quickly.
Let's see how fast I can read these.
All right,
this is going to be a fucking train wreck.
Simple faith.
I'm not gonna read these first simple faith.
Everybody.
Thousands of people seeking home security get ripped off every day.
And the home security industry wants you to believe it's your only option.
They've got hoards of salesmen out there trying to scare you into signing one of
their longterm contracts.
She gets stuck writing huge checks month after month with no way out.
It's robbery by contract and it can cost you thousands,
but there's a better way to protect your home with simple faith.
Home Security.
Simple faith has no contracts.
None.
You'll get award winning 24,
seven protection named best in the industry.
Uh,
security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the purple,
uh,
the police.
And it's just 1499 a month,
$14 and 99 cents.
That's less than half of what most companies charge.
Protect your home this smart way.
Visit simple faith.
Uh,
bird.com there's no slashes,
nothing.
I'm going to guess this a slash there's simple safe slash bird.com but they st
simple safe bird.com try one or the other for an exclusive 10% offer and get a
free key chain remote worth $25 only.
When you go to simple flight bird.com that's simple faith bird.com MVMT watches
everybody when you're in your early twenties and thirties,
money can be tight.
Um,
if you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank account.
Like spending four to 500 bucks on a department store.
Watch.
There's some brands out there that are charging insane prices for watches that
don't even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go up,
it's still have enough money to buy him or her a drink.
Checkout Movement,
watches.com I've seen them before and these watches are sharp originally found
by two,
founded by two broke college kids movement watches.
Cut out the middle man and they're big brand retail markups and yeah,
cut out the middleman in there.
Big brand retail markups in order to give you a stylish watch for an affordable
price movement.
Watches just starting at $95 a watch with department store quality for a
fraction of the price.
They're sleek and minimal ethic.
A modern twist on a classic style movement has grown occasionally,
organically,
sorry,
purely by support is like you said,
join there more than 1 million social media media followers and getting a
movement watched today.
Go to MVMT watches.com/burr and they'll save you 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches.com/burr and lastly,
but not leastly dollar shave club dude.
Um,
people's,
uh,
dollar shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your door for third,
the price of what?
The greedy razor,
razor corporate razor,
razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
You get a first class shave when use the executive blade,
and that's without even hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive blade with the doctor cabbies,
easy shave
Dr Carver's shave butter the blade gently.
Uh,
the blade just gently glides for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter is in your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
Uh,
now's a great time to join dollar shave club.
New members who buy a tube of shave butter.
Get a month on the of the executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/burr.
And lastly,
if you want to donate to this podcast without it costing your fucking dime,
anytime you're going to buy something on Amazon,
if you go to my podcast page,
you click on,
um,
the little Amazon link there.
It takes you right to Amazon,
doesn't cost you any extra money.
And I get credit for driving traffic there if you want to.
If you don't,
that's fucking cool to um,
a Nia,
do you want to read this thing with me?
Okay.
All right.
Well that's the end of the podcast.
Um,
but she's going to come here in the end and we're going to a,
I dunno,
a little bonus,
like five minute thing here.
This could go south very easily,
but uh,
we'll see what happens.
Hang on,
let me hit plus.
All right,
the lovely knee.
Everybody.
Hi,
how are you?
I'm great,
thanks.
Okay,
let's get right down to,
okay.
All right.
This guy,
he's dating this woman.
She thinks she's beautiful,
but she's Harry this thing again.
Well,
yeah,
but I never,
you never talked to about,
we never got a female's advice on this.
I thought we did.
You talked about it.
Yeah,
I remember I said like either like he sorta get something wax and they go
together and it's funny or he just like gets over it.
You said that on the podcast or did we talk about that on our own?
Not on the podcast.
And you got all mad at me cause I was like if she is not,
what do you have against talking into the mic?
I don't know.
You just sit there and go.
Like I said,
I have is,
I know people tweeted me the last time was like I can't hear you so I you've
told me
just have it follow your,
your,
your mouth.
Okay.
But because the thing is I feel like if a microphone is anywhere near me,
it's going to microphone my voice amplified.
Wow.
So I don't need,
it's very rare that someone makes me look like the smart one.
Microphone.
My voice.
So,
um,
well what you have to know about it but microphones,
each one of them they have,
there's ones that are designed to pick up three 60.
There's ones that are like,
these ones are like directly on.
Okay.
That's directly on that.
The reason for that is if there's other background noise that you don't want to
pick that up.
There's other microphones design where you want to hear the whole room.
These are directly on,
so you got to speak into it.
But this is not what we're talking about.
Okay.
Sorry.
All right,
so somebody,
somebody's got this and she's got like a like hair on her lower back.
Yeah.
Like right with a tramp stamp would be,
she was like,
she could have a tramp stamp and he wouldn't know cause it's,
there's a whole thicket of tear under there.
Yeah.
I thought we talked about this.
I thought you stopped saying that.
Okay.
I understand that.
You think that we talked about it.
Neither one of us can remember if we did it on the podcast and not,
this is just bonus time.
Anyways,
so refresh our listeners.
Well,
my date and a woman,
she's got a fucking Afro right above her butt crack.
What do you say?
There's nothing wrong with an Afro.
Um,
on your head.
A booboo boo.
I think you
answer the God damn.
This is just,
this is just,
it's a tough one.
How long has he been dating this person?
It.
Can he be like,
so what's with your little furry back over here?
You're like my little Chia pet in a cute way.
Like can he say it in a cute way?
How do you say that in a cute way?
I don't know.
Oh,
you my little Chia pet back here?
No.
Um,
you know what?
Maybe he could just sort of like,
this is gonna sound really fucking weird,
but maybe the sort of like stroke it or whatever the thing is.
She'll probably like,
oh God no,
don't touch that.
I know there's like a hair back there.
It's so like weird.
I hate it.
And you can go,
why don't you get it wax?
And she might be like,
I don't know.
Like I'm embarrassed.
I'll go with you.
I'll whack something with you.
How about that?
I'll whack something.
You lack something and then boom.
Not a good idea.
I have an idea to,
what about when you know,
if she's wearing like a sexy shirt so it's doesn't quite reach down to her pants
when she goes to get up off,
he's probably doesn't wear shirts like that.
When she goes to get up off the couch,
you just reach up and grab a little back,
can't go back down here,
pull back lying on her stomach at the beach and he starts braiding it for her.
I know.
It's bad.
It's kind of a questionable situation.
Well this one guy was saying he was dating this woman.
She had like even hairy feet.
She'll like hairy toes.
Shit happens man.
I know,
but what the fuck me,
you got to handle that.
I mean,
ideally,
yes you would handle that in a perfect world,
in a perfect world.
But you know,
I had girlfriends for a years who had a little like just like the little shade
of a mustache and they just never,
it just never really occurred to them to wax it until like recently.
And I remember I had a friend,
I saw her,
I hadn't seen her in awhile and she was like,
do you notice anything different?
And she kept turning her face in a certain way and I was like,
you get your upper lip wax rental and yeah,
she's like,
I finally did it.
She's like,
I don't know.
I was always just intimidated to go into the place.
And she's like,
but I'm so glad I did.
So I fix that.
What it is.
Yeah,
people are self conscious and you think you'll go in there and you'll get
judgment by the waxing person,
but the waxing person has waxed,
you know Chewbacca down there so they don't care.
That's their job.
So it could be that she's just like a little embarrassed to go to a place and
have it taken off because who wants to say,
oh,
I have to go get my back wax today before you don't have to say that.
You just walk down and go,
Hey,
can you watch my back?
You don't even have to whisper it.
And I know you don't.
So,
oh no.
But if you go there to other people,
see you getting your back waxed?
No,
no,
no.
You're in a private room.
Oh,
whenever you get any kind of waxing service,
it's not like Steve Brill.
Yeah,
exactly.
so you're in a private thing,
so he just has to do it in a cute,
you know what,
this one asshole did what?
He goes,
I suggest you don't tell the woman that she's Harry.
He told the woman,
he broke up with her and said the reason why he was doing it was because she was
so hairy is that's not the way it is.
Isn't that the meanest thing you've ever fucking mean his thing ever.
Are you that shallow because that's something that's easily fixable or are you
that fucking shallow that you break up with someone?
It's like cause you and Harry back.
Like what a fucking asshole.
Back feet,
nose,
blood coming out of the nose and then the arms.
That's just,
that's unnecessary to say that after the fact,
if you love somebody and there's,
even if you don't,
even if you don't love somebody,
you don't do that to somebody.
That's not,
that's not okay.
But then so since she fucking,
he came,
she started throwing plates and he fucking left and then came back.
She had dumped bleach on his clothes and stapled some condoms to the fucking
wall.
The usual destruction of property that for some reason to use validated.
Do you have,
I have never actually noticed.
Do you have back here yet?
But he came back here yet like cause I feel like that's something that as men
get older,
I have actually never not turned around.
Now I don't have back here.
Well let me say,
well Jesus Christ near your fucking sleep next to me every goddamn day.
Just never thought to look for that.
Now I don't have back here.
You know what?
There is a very fine little area in the lower back tramp stamp area.
Not a lot.
You can barely see it cause your hair so fair.
But like,
no,
I don't know.
You have a very small like yeah I got nothing back there.
There's nothing back there.
I mean there's more on your chest then on the your lower very small amount.
But the thing is,
I feel like in 10 years that shit could get a little thing and 10 years I'm
going to be close to 60.
I mean I'd still have you accent what?
In 10 years when my white fucking back hair against my white back because it
bothers you when I wear a fucking a half shirt.
I mean what,
what it was,
what are we doing at that point?
That's a fair way.
Look at my lower back.
Let's just do,
let's just,
no you don't.
No you don't.
You don't.
Um,
yeah,
I try to be very familiar with your lower back.
You don't?
Oh yeah,
you don't,
you're not a hairy person
so,
but if I was Harry back there,
would you say something to me?
No,
I just would've broke up with you.
What's so you would have broken up over cause I wanted to taking the time to
fall in love with you.
If you're walking around looking like fucking Burt Reynolds and playgirl.
Okay.
Oh,
I see it.
Photoshop coming.
Oh my God.
Wait,
shout out to the m M Photoshop on sweater.
Oh my God,
Dude.
That one with me standing in front of the fountain.
I fucking dude,
we were in the writers room when I saw that and I fucking laughed so hard.
Yeah,
like one of the other writers is going like,
what?
What?
And I showed it to him and everyone was going like,
oh my God,
that's so mean.
I go,
this is fucking hilarious.
And then I love the picture of you that they found you was one.
Yeah.
It was like when you were going out to some event,
so you look,
that was us at the heat premiere.
Yeah,
that's what that picture was.
I was trying to be like fucking,
you know modest about it.
I didn't want to sit there and say you were at a movie premiere.
I said you had some big event.
You always got to be standing there.
You always have to fucking drop the Hollywood shit though.
The premiere for the cinematic film,
the heat where my husband had two lines.
You had more than two lines.
If you sneezed in that movie,
you missed me.
But now,
but now everybody follow the m m Photoshop on Twitter.
Whoever that is,
man or woman is fucking hilarious.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Actually have better one for the m Photoshop.
All right,
so wait,
where's my phone?
Because I wrote it down.
Remember you said the name of a movie and it was once again how you have just
sort of clues from the movie and I don't remember the titles.
All right,
so I'm going to find it because it was definitely one of your classic ones and
we're not going to say what the movie is.
We're just going to have the MM Photoshop.
Wait,
let me see if I can find it.
Mock it up,
put it on Twitter and then everyone will be able to guess.
Hopefully.
All right,
so you called this movie.
I'm going to kill you on Wall Street.
They're fuck,
oh,
I'm going to kill it on Wall Street.
They're fuck.
Oh,
that's it.
That was a movie.
That's a movie.
So people are going to try to guess what it is.
Mm,
Photoshop is going to know.
It's funny.
Days later.
Movie poster days later.
You reading that?
It now sounds like somebody else says it.
Said it,
and that's a terrible clue.
That's not even close.
It's sort of close.
They'll figure it out.
All right,
well,
okay,
it's 12 minutes past the hour here.
It's time to wrap this up cause weapon.
It's passed the House passed the hour.
Wb.
You are.
Our morning becomes eclectic.
I love her.
You listened to that.
You think it makes you smarter.
All right,
that's it.
Now it's so pretentious to be smart out Kcrw,
so you get a variety of musical style.
Same liberal viewpoint.
All right,
you done this,
this over.
Can I?
Can I go somewhere and eat my oatmeal?
You know what it is?
I just,
I don't like shit.
That's a hundred percent liberal or 100% conservative.
All right.
That's fine.
I like in the middle because both of them caused me to yell at them.
Bill will yell at everything.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Not True because nothing is exactly your viewpoint.
I don't yell at you what?
I don't yell at the dog.
That's also not true.
I don't yell at other drivers.
I'm courteous and polite.
Okay.
I don't yell at inanimate objects like my computer.
I don't do any of those things.
Sure.
Well,
then,
all right,
then I want to know,
you're like a redheaded Gandhi.
I definitely was like Ben Kingsley's more than I look like fucking Danny,
Danny Bonaduce.
Alright,
that's the,
uh,
that's the podcast here for the,
for this Monday.
Jenny been a don't shake.
You got a situation with Danny Bonaduce.
Dude,
we got to take them care.
The fucking,
all right,
that's it.
I'll talk to you Fuckos on Thursday.
Go Fuck Yourself.